in the beginning there was nothing an  infinite void then in an instant  everything known to man came into being  the Big Bang the birth of time itself  chaos and beauty a beauty that created  infinite galaxies galaxies that was when  they create the unimaginable why but  even more incredible the human brain the  pinnacle of billions of years of  evolution  a brain that possesses the power of  reason and the ability to ponder life's  most ancient riddles  why are we here is there intelligent  life beyond our galaxy or the one  question that has puzzled mankind since  the beginning of time  if God exists and why do we make ugly  people 200 Lander no Derek Zoolander  it's like a fun but I don't spend my  name with the - fine how about Zoolander  III no Zoolander 2 but with Roman  numerals but I'm not Italian  Jesus you are so freaking stupid  it's insane a slob irritated easily then  text I'm spotless aviation the until as  does the international finance method  suits after